euh donc vous restez là et vous voulez
construire l'avenir avec euh plusque
jamais c'est-à-dire que je vais essayer
dans l'opposition avec avec mon équipe
et que je vais essayer si vous voulez
pour les prochaines échéances d'être le
plus utile possible non pas pour
moi-même je ne fais pas une habileté ce
soir je dis simplement qu'on peut
compter sur ma détermination et ma
passion totale pour faire en sorte que
nous soyons en mesure de désigner celui
ou celle qui sera notre champion pour
les prochaines législatur
et puis l'équipe qui aura la charge de
faire en sorte si vous voulez que pour
les municipales on puisse gagner voilà
implicitement c'est une forme de
critique contre l'organisation qui a eu
lieu jusqu'à présent tant pour les pour
les municipal c'està-dire contre
vous-même non non mais attendez chacun
on va parler tranquillement pour faire
le point des choses réussies des échecs
des erreurs des choses positives et
cetera ça bien sûrin ça ça ne me pose
aucun problème et j'ai ma part de
responsabilité je suis pas là pour
reporter sur d'autres
les choses je pense simplement que si je
n'avais pas mené cette campagne avec
beaucoup d'appreté souvenez-vous un
certain nombre de pronostics on disait
que jean-germain allait gagner au
premier tour souvenez-vous des attaques
que j'ai subi quand on a dit que j'étais
nommé à Bruxelles c'était de la
désinformation permettez-moi de vous
dire que parfois ça s'est trouvé sans
guillemets c'est-à-dire que c'était pas
uniquement les propos tenus par telle ou
telle personnalité c'est devenu des
stratégies enfin voilà tout ça si vous
voulez fait partie d'une d'une réalité
c'était une victoire attendue espér
est-ce que vous voyez des gens justement
pour qui vous allez donc aider est-ce
que reconstru savez que le vote à
l'intérieur d'une grande famille
politique c'est quelque chose
d'important donc le moment venu on va
déterminer entre nous qui sera quelle
sera la femme ou l'homme qui sera notre
porte drapeau pour un certain nombre
d'échéances pourquoi la droite est aussi
faible dans aussi bien on le voit à tour
que pas uniquement pas uniquement en
andrloir malheureusement vous voyez la
vague nationale qui s'est manifester je
prends l'exemple de quelqu'un qui est un
maire remarquable Gilles de Robien
pensez que Gilles deobien il est battu
dans sa propre ville c'est un type qui a
fait des choses extraordinaires il a le
cœur sur la main et cetera donc voilà
les électeurs à un moment ou à un autre
ils avaient beaucoup de choses dans le
crâne quand on regarde les chiffres là
bureau par bureau j'ai regardé ça
évidemment très très vite il y a des
bureaux si vous voulez au fond les gens
ne se sont pas mobilisés pour le deuxème
tour et où on a il y a moins de de
suffrages exprimés qu'au qu'au premier
tour et ça ça a été évidemment à ce
moment-là très favorable à Germain dans
les endroits où les gens se sont dit ce
n'est pas plié on a vraiment vraiment
amélioré notre score simplement voilà le
le le score du premier tour bah il était
pas bon deuxièmement vous avez un
certain nombre de gens il faut dire les
choses qui voulaient ma peau voilà qui
ont appelé à ne pas voter pour moi donc
de toute façon eux ils ont fait mais
attendez vous avez entendu les
déclarations par exemple de Guillaume
Peltier il a clairement au fond depuis
le début son objectif c'était quoi
c'était qui est place nette et pour
qu'il puisse puisse être une sorte de
relève un jour face à jean-germain et
bien on le laissera pas faire et on a
dans nos rangs des hommes et des femmes
qui ont beaucoup de talents et moi je
vais tout faire pour les épauler et pour
faire en sorte qu'ils puissent réussir
on ne se laissera pas arbitrer de
l'extérieur voilà c'est quelque chose de
très clair et c'est aussi une sorte de
de serment qu'entre nous on a passé
c'est-à-dire c'est-à-dire entre vous
c'est entre vos colis ou al entre la fam
quip g si vous voulez qui sont
aujourd'hui voilà meurtris par
globalement au plan national comme au
plan local par la victoire de la gauche
le que le Conseil Général bascule à
gauche c'est quand même absolument
catastrophique catastrophique
heureusement qu'il y a Serge qui va être
notre porte- drapeau de ce point de vue
là et c'est évidemment quelque chose qui
nous a tous ce soir mis un beau mot cœur
absolument considérable et ça c'est bien
quand quand vous dites catastrophique
monsieur donne Dieu vous vous y allez
fort parce que au fond et on le voyait
tout à l'heure il y a une évolution
sociologique qui fait que la Touren
change ces ces représentants si vous
voulez il y a une nouvelle image qui
sera donnée par une
présidente bon pas catastrophique disons
que la droite a perdu mais la Touren
s'appauvrit ah ça je sais pas si Laou
oui la Touren s'appauvrit le le revenu
moyen de la ville de tour c'est 985 €
inférieur à la moyenne départementale 36
% logement
ok voilà mais un nombre vous le savez
très bien qu'un certain nombre de
direction
important de certaines entreprises
foutent le camp ailleurs dans d'autres
villes de notre région enfin de notre
région au sens global du terme au man à
anger à Orléan donc voilà il y a une
espèce de nécessité d'énergie
supplémentaire mais là on a eu le
sentiment que voilà que dans une phase
où il y a beaucoup d'inquiétude bien au
fond comme le dit le vieux proverbe on
sait ce qu'on a et on ne sait pas ce
qu'on trouve voilà et donc les gens se
sont dit n'ont pas cru à notre énergie
donc moi évidemment ça me ça m'at triste
et maintenant ils vont avoir à gérer un
certain nombre des engagements et des
déflagrations de jean-germain voilà mais
c'est triste hein c'est triste et
simplement on va